hey what's up guys my name is luciano
back at it again
with one of these sweet code review
videos this is just a little series on
my channel where you guys send me some
code and i take a look at it now last
time was the first episode of this
series i'll have it linked up there and
since then there have been quite a lot
of submissions from you guys as well
some questions as to
what kind of code i'll be looking at so
i'll try and answer that today but the
short answer is if you want me to review
your code check out
the uh email address in the description
below it's what is it like china review
gmail.com you can send your code there
as well as a little description of what
the code actually is and if there's
a specific area that you want me to
review in particular now the first thing
i want to mention is there have been
like a lot of submissions and it's a
little bit difficult for me to obviously
pick one and and review it my area of
expertise is of course game engines so i
do like looking at game engines but that
is not the only thing i want to look at
we are going to be looking at another
game engine last time we covered like a
2d game engine made by a 13 year old
this person is 17. um we'll dive into
this email in a minute
uh and this is as far as i'm concerned a
3d game engine
kind of based on hazel so this should be
a little bit of familiar code
maybe this uh my hope is that this kind
of code review will
hopefully help guide some of the people
who are following my game engine series
but also trying to write some of their
own code because for those of you don't
know of course
i do have a game engine series here on
youtube but if you have a project that
is in another language
if you have a project that is just a
game or a game engine or an
implementation of some algorithm and
like a visualizer to go with it
feel free to send that as well it
doesn't have to be game engine it
doesn't have to be cfos plus but anyway
i don't want to spend
half an hour talking about this series
in general if you have some code that
you want me to review
check the email address in the
description of the video let's dive in
and take a look at
dmitri vasiliev so
dimitri is from ukraine which is pretty
cool
and he's 17. so a little bit of a uh
age difference between 13 year old but
still still not like professional code
right i'm kind of building
towards that maybe we'll get into like
someone who is like some engineer at a
company and they have a hobby project
and they want
me to code review that that would be
interesting as well but you know this
should be a step
up from the 13 year old code that we
looked at last time by the way a little
bit of a precursor
i'm assuming that they're more
experienced because they're older that's
not necessarily the case so
actually i could be wrong i'm currently
working on my own game engine because
it's a great practice project i want to
be an engine developer
maybe there's a chance for me to write
something new and amazing for the
industry it now can render a rotating
cube and much more maybe put a test
engine sound like threshing cube okay
cube
implies 3d so this should be in fact a
3d engine i want to improve every aspect
of engine so i'd be very grateful if you
can point out my mistakes and explain
how to fix them
link to github repository is here let me
look at that
and you'll find all the instructions
inside thank you also thank you a lot
for your content and this review
sorry for my english working on it
people who don't speak english as the
first language always
say this and their english is usually
very good so yeah well done
okay so here we have the code looks like
cmake is in use here and we can clone it
recursively
and there are actually build
instructions which is pretty good i
think that's more than hazel has
cma 3.17 clone uh you know
standard cmake stuff here and if you
build a sandbox project we need to add
this option okay so good thing i read
this
um or you can use c line all right and
then we can generate this okay so we're
going to dive in and generate a
visual studio solution file with the
sandbox project i guess and we'll try
and compile and run it first i might
just skip past that part
um and then we'll actually dive in and
look at the code but first first
this video is sponsored by skillshare
those of you who still don't know what
skillshare is skillshare is an amazing
online learning community
where millions of creative and curious
people from all around the world can
come together
and learn some new skills because
learning new skills is both fun and
incredibly helpful in life now whilst
i'm from melbourne australia and we're
finally coming out of our lockdown i
know that europe's kind of going into
a bit of a lockdown at the moment and
one of the things that i actually did to
help me get through lockdown was
i tried to be productive right if you
are stuck at home and you can't go
outside and you can't hang out with your
friends as much
then instead of just watching netflix
just binge watching it the whole
the whole way through and then feeling
bad about yourself you can actually use
some of that time to do something
productive and learn a new skill
i know that makes me feel a lot better
and i stay a lot healthier
mentally and that of course is where
skillshare comes in they have
thousands of amazing classes on pretty
much any topic you could think of
whether you're interested in art or
illustration or like logo design or
business and marketing or productivity
or photography or editing photos or
anything like that
they have a bunch of amazing classes for
me one of my personal favorites is this
art and illustration course by
jazza jazza has a youtube channel i'm
sure a lot of people have heard of him
but he also has this amazing
like really well put together skillshare
course which
can function as a really good
introduction to illustration and just
drawing in general which is something
that i love to do for fun just to chill
out after a long day
and i love the fact that the classes are
so bite-sized a lot of the videos in the
classes are like between
five and ten minutes so even if you just
have a few minutes at the end of the day
it's so easy to sit down and actually
do something productive for a limited
time skillshare is offering you guys a
free trial so definitely jump on that
link in the description below
check it out see what kind of courses
skillshare has in general and go ahead
and learn
some new skills huge thank you to
skillshare as always for sponsoring this
video now the first thing i want to do
with this
is obviously try and build it according
to these settings i just want to
start off by saying that even though
we're not into the code this kind of
documentation is great
right when i look at a repository like
this the first thing that i want to see
is what the project is which it clearly
states
and a getting started guide that
actually has instructions on how to
obtain it and how to build it
these instructions aren't that long so
he could have left them here but i mean
it doesn't matter at all
the point is that they're here it's
really easy to actually
build this project the instructions are
all here there's even a plan and
a little cute little mention to my hazel
video so thank you for that but my point
is
it's really nicely organized and i don't
have to think twice about
what on earth this even is now once the
project matures a little bit more it's
really nice to see a screenshot of what
it's capable of rendering
now i don't do this in hazel if we look
at hazel it's just kind of got like the
the logo here and then that's kind of it
i mean it's got instructions on getting
started as you can see and the plan as
well
and all of that stuff but it doesn't
have a screenshot we're not really
rendering anything exciting yet i don't
think he is either
but that's just something to keep in
mind for the future if you're actually
working on something visual
then it's good to include some
screenshots okay so i'm gonna grab the
link
i've got a little uh let's call this
well we'll just clone it over here so
i'll just make a
um i'll go open a command prompt here
get
clone recursive we'll dump that in here
and then
we will once this clones we'll compile
it with cmake this was actually quite
fast so i'll probably just
not even have to skip through this okay
so let's let's take a look at this in
the meantime
so we've got glad we've got glfw got glm
we've got i'm going
we've got spd log speed lock this is
basically the same setup as
hazel it does say that it's inspired by
hazel so um
we'll see uh what kind of modifications
he's made for the record a lot of people
tend to ask me if it's okay for them to
kind of copy hazel
um like of course it is right this is a
tutorial series for you guys
my hope is that you would take what you
like from it and then maybe change some
things that you don't like and then add
a whole bunch of your own stuff to it um
you know it's it's
there's no there's no reason to ask me
if it's okay to copy the code now if you
just
copy the whole repository and then just
change the name from hazel to
walnut engine or something like that i
don't know then that's kind of like
that's a bit lame you know it's not
not very cool but if you're obviously
learning from it and then
molding it into your own work that's
kind of the idea so let's make a
directory called build we'll go into
build and then we'll just run cmake like
that
subdirectory uh okay i just completely
failed there let's actually go into
um what was it called real engine and
then we'll make our build directory and
then we'll go into the build directory
and then we'll see make there we go
okay so pretty oh whoa okay let's stop
i remembered so this is why it's so good
to read the the instructions
you need to add this let's go ahead and
add that so c make
dot dot paste again so this should also
i guess
include the build examples which is
going to be good or other it's going to
include the examples
okay and of course it hasn't worked now
even though cma seems to have failed
it it does seem to have generated like a
solution file i might just open that i
don't really
like debugging cmake i don't think
anyone does it looks like
it's saying that cmake may not be built
correctly but i'm pretty sure i've been
using it for a while on this computer
so a little bit weird on a side note
this is why i love pre-make so much i
have had
pretty much zero issues with pre-make
and all the issues
with cmake okay so real engine engine
uh i guess we'll look at the cube
example hopefully this will just build
i'm not sure if it will because of the
cma issues i described earlier
but let's take a look at this okay so
there's a bunch of custom build rules
for all of these different
uh projects because i imagine they also
support cmake which is nice
one of the downsides obviously with
using something like pre-make because
you have to write scripts for
anything that doesn't include it where a
cmake is pretty much standard so
uh that's definitely helping out in this
example and if we hit f5 hopefully this
will run there we go it runs now i can't
open
shader's bass glsl um so it looks like
we can't load a shader file
interestingly enough though it didn't
crash or anything like that which is
nice
it's just running with a black screen
let's see if i can quickly diagnose this
and have it actually open the file so
it's supposed to be in shaders
let's see uh what the working directory
is set to it's directly properties
debugging working directory is set to
the bin
folder this might actually be the issue
um
because perhaps oh here it is so in the
bin folder there's debug shaders and
then
shaders in here is empty so this should
probably be the working directory
so it's just missing a debug yeah a
little bit weird again this might have
been a cmake thing
i'll just set it manually because this
is a code review and i just want to see
it running properly there we go
okay so a bit of a white cube here uh i
guess the shaders is just
just setting a flat color and everything
else looks pretty good obviously similar
to hazel here with like the logging and
different coloring and
all that stuff but we have a point to
get started so the next step for me here
is going to be just to dive in and take
a look at the general structure of
things
now i already imagine that this is going
to be fairly fairly similar to hazel
which is kind of making me think that
maybe this was almost a mistake picking
this one because it's it's
probably going to have a very similar uh
kind of layout but maybe i'm wrong maybe
there's been some stuff that's been
added
let's take a look at this obviously the
big thing that i'm looking for is the
fact that
the hazel hazel in the game engine
series on youtube is not 3d yet whereas
this seems to be 3d so i'm interested to
see
how this person has actually kind of
integrated 3d rendering even though it
is just a flatly lit
kind of or a flat shaded white cube and
we'll see if we can
review that code specifically okay so
this is the main example of the real
example cube now obviously i'm seeing a
lot of kind of engine code inside this
even though it is an example so that's
kind of the first thing i'll point out
um you know there's there's like setting
up the actual cube here
application init these are all things
that i don't like to do
inside the actual client app so to speak
now the reason is that
application init from within this real
engine
this is something that i have no doubt
has to happen for every single
application so this is just like part of
the engine startup
why is it the application's
responsibility to call that you know
there's no
there's no way around calling
application init right i imagine that
this hap
absolutely has to be called i mean this
is actually this is it initializes the
render of the window
all of that stuff so why have it here
why not have it as part of the engine
startup
now i don't know maybe i should bring up
hazel and kind of
talk about the architecture with that
but we'll see if you guys if you guys
have any ideas for how i can maybe be
more effective in these code reviews and
and what stuff you're interested in then
definitely leave a comment below but
i'll just kind of take this as it is for
now
okay share the live reload okay my first
question is immediately where does the
shader library come from right because
this is a variable we're in the init
function
this is a variable right so it's a
pointer in this case it's a
real reference which is just a shared
pointer so we do a similar thing
of course within hazel um but you can
see that just
kind of in this private section of this
class we're
just creating this right over here now
that might be okay because shader
library is just a
uh like it's a very kind of um
straightforward
kind of simple to initialize class right
simple to instantiate class
it's not like it does any kind of opengl
code or anything that's dependent on
anything else
it just creates an empty unordered map
and that's it so it's totally fine to
initialize it here but then my second
question is
why is it a reference why is it a shared
pointer
i don't imagine this would get passed
anywhere
and you can see it doesn't so my first
kind of advice would be
probably just get rid of this you know
just have a stack allocated shader
library
like that um and then
you don't have to uh don't have to
allocate it on the heap
and it's a lot simpler i mean it doesn't
change like the actual
kind of api that much right but it
it just it's something that you just
don't need to do and that you shouldn't
make a habit out of
same with all of these like um you know
these might be passed into an api that
expects
like a shared pointer or a reference
cannon object and that's fine in which
case i would create them on the heap
but you know for the most part these are
probably not going to
suffer if you don't create them on the
heap especially for this example
yeah so you can see kind of in this in
this um case right
um ad index buffer takes a reference in
so
you know unless you want to write your
api twice it's just best to just stick
with the references and i get that
that's totally fine
um also i won't jump ahead
uh let's let's continue going over here
okay so we load this shader sure fine um
now this is a shader library so i wonder
how this person is going to reference
this next
so obviously we're taking a file name
here does it automatically get the name
from the file like how do we a library
obviously
uh implies to me that we have a library
filled with shaders and we want to be
able to retrieve shaders later so how do
we retrieve them
shader name seems to be a function um
potentially i can't really go to it
unfortunately
shader name here it is um and then name
gets set here and i imagine that maybe
it's just the the file name yep so i
think we do a similar thing in hazel
or at least in hiddle dev um so in other
words this would probably treat it as
bass and if i want to get in the future
i can just retrieve the bass
shader so that's fine okay setting up
rendering here so we have a bunch of
vertices
for our cube and we have a bunch of well
it's called positions but these are
indices so i would definitely rename
them to indices because
um whilst i guess technically speaking
these are vertex positions and there's
no colors or whatever in here
um it's probably not not great to have
them like this
also um keep in mind this cube isn't
really going to work
so what what what you've done is you've
got
a total of eight vertices here
describing the cube
um i mean for a cube this may be lit
like with a flat color or in your shader
you're just setting it to white that's
totally fine you can physically get it
to render but when you start to do any
kind of lighting calculations
you'll need to have normals and normals
you can't have
one normal per each kind of vertex in
this case
here let me just illustrate this this is
something that a lot of people
get wrong so if we have a cube pretend
that this is a cube
and we've decided to have a total of
eight
kind of vertices here so if you kind of
draw the cube
you wind up with a cube technically
because you really only need
eight of them right so it looks
something like this and you obviously
have your cube and it looks like a cube
the problem is that when you want to
start doing lighting
you'll need to actually know which
direction all of these faces are facing
in so that you can see how much
how much they're facing the light right
so to do that you'll need normals and
normals
point in the direction of the face now
if you've only got one vertex you can
only have one vertex normal
it doesn't really make sense because
even though it has physically one
position
if you think about it it's part of this
face which is pointing this way
it's part of this face which is pointing
this way
and then it's also part of that kind of
back face that's pointing that way
right so in in actual fact you need
three vertices in this one place they
have the same position
but they have different normals now
there are no normals here which is why
it's working fine and
and consequently you can see that you're
not doing any kind of lighting in that
flat white cube that we looked at
earlier but for the future this is
something that you'll need so in other
words even though you might think that
you can get away with eight vertices for
a cube
in reality you'll need 24 of them
because you need to
there are still some that you can
duplicate so in other words if we have
kind of a triangle if we have this face
which is made up of two triangles
we only really need four vertices to
represent this because even though we
have two vertices here that are the same
one belonging to this triangle one
belonging to this triangle
they still are facing the same direction
so we can get away with them having the
same normals
but you know when you're talking about
all of these different faces facing
different ways you'll need more than
that so that's just a little bit of
information regarding cubes because
because i remember back in the day i
used to struggle with this as well i
thought why on earth would i need more
than eight vertices to represent a cube
there's just eight points in 3d space
and that's correct but
again a vertex is not just a position it
can have other
other data attached to it such as a
normal and if you want to have different
data per vertex then you might have to
duplicate the position
because it's not just all about the
position okay back to the code positions
um yeah so these are all the indices now
just a little quick note i would
probably recommend just
uh once you have like the ability to
load 3d models
it'd be very useful to actually just
load a 3d model that contains all of
this in it
the reason is that writing stuff out
like this
is kind of useful and a lot of engines
have something called a mesh factory
that can generate this but it is also a
little bit of a headache
i don't know i'm kind of torn on this
because on one hand it's good to learn
about this and it's good to learn about
how you can manually like position a
cube but
it's also not it's also like very
tedious i think for a beginner to do
i'm not sure leave a comment below with
whether or not you think a beginner
will say i'm not sure i'm not calling
this person a beginner but for the sake
of this example we'll pretend that
they're a beginner
is it a good idea for a beginner to be
kind of manually you know building
meshes up like this or should i just try
and load a 3d model what's better
because i can't really decide
one thing i do want to note that i was i
could probably keep talking about this
cube for like the whole
video but um one thing i'm also noticing
here is it's not like a
one by one meter cube so generally when
we have like basic primitive types basic
meshes we want them to be
uh some kind of consistent size usually
about one meter in either like
you know the diameter or the radius you
can decide which one you want usually
radius
sorry usually the whole diameter would
be one meter and then also
like for this you probably want the cube
to be one by one meter
right or one by one centimeter depending
on what units you're using
this is obviously two by two right
because we go from positive one to
negative one
the problem with this is that it kind of
throw it can throw off the scale of the
rest of your 3d rendering scale is
something that's really important scale
is something that people don't
really think about that often either but
just know that when you're making stuff
like this
you should just make it kind of you know
be i guess
one by one unit and then you can
obviously scale it to whatever size you
want
uh okay positions sure we've gone
through that okay
vo reset um see this is like another
kind of consequence of using these
shared pointers
i don't personally don't not a huge fan
of calling a reset
um you can probably just set it equal to
something like this right um and you
might have to do like a make shared and
then
i guess that's probably why you've done
it this way but i think i just think dot
reset looks a little bit messy
um because you're basically substituting
like an assignment like an equal sign
for a function called reset bind
um not sure why you're binding here
so see this is just another example of a
of like an api that's doing too much in
the client
right um what you probably should do is
like if you
really do want to construct your own
vertex array and then your own kind of
vertex buffer and index buffer
then what you should do instead is um
and we can get into this stuff in a
minute but what you can do instead is
just maybe add them
correctly like that without having to
like bind them then this does any kind
of binding it needs to if you actually
want to like for example link the index
buffer to a vertex array because the
like one of the ways that you you do
that is by actually just binding the
vertex three and then binding the
index buff and then it magically links
open gel is annoying um
but anyway uh that's a lot better
without having to kind of uh
i guess put that responsibility onto the
client because if you look at this
you know this becomes a little bit
complicated already right like if i want
to render a cube
this data is kind of necessary because
for the sake of this we'll pretend that
instead of being like this is how my
engine renders the cube because that's a
bit ridiculous you don't want to have to
write out all this code to render a cube
let's pretend that the kind of for the
sake of this
that this is how our engine renders the
custom shape in which we provide the
vertices and
the indices right so if if this is our
custom data that we're providing that
obviously needs to be there
but then this i think could be a lot
more simplified so you could for example
make a vertex array
don't worry about binding it you can set
the layout because that needs to be done
into the vertex buffer
this code needs to be here obviously and
then this code needs to be here
obviously
right and then i guess you need to add
it somehow but like all the kind of
binding
and the you know that stuff doesn't need
to be here you want to keep it as simple
as possible
you could even write a kind of
constructor for a vertex array
that actually takes in a vertex buffer
and an index buffer and like a layout or
something like that
so that it's really easy to just be like
hey i have this
information right i have this data and
this is my layout
that's my vertex array please like save
this so that i can use it to render
later
now these code reviews are getting
difficult if you guys let let me know
with
if you guys are okay with like a one
hour code review every time i do this
then please let me know because i kind
of
consciously want to keep this on 20
minutes but this is it's impossible to
review a 3d engine
um or even like something of this size
which isn't that big
in this amount of time maybe i'm just
going through this way too finely but
it's kind of it's kind of fun and i'm
seeing a lot of things here
okay i want to mention that uh using the
standard math library
not the biggest defense but you've got
glm use glm
right you've got a math library that
presumably supports like
intrinsics and ssc and all that stuff i
don't think i don't know if the
standard library supports that stuff to
be honest so
maybe i'm wrong but i would use glm
instead of all of this stuff
just to be consistent with your math
library as well not to mention that
you know this if you use the standard
math library you're kind of leaving that
up to the compiler so you might see
different speeds across different
platforms with different compilers
whereas uh you know glm is presumably
going to be stable
um okay camera position camera lookout
so what this
yeah okay so we're looking at a point
this is probably just going to do a
lookout matrix yeah
all right cool update view projection
and then we create a uh
projection times view okay sure pretty
sounding camera class here
render okay so this is interesting right
so we start a scene we get our transform
so this is going to be oh we actually
have a transform
so transform is a uh
matrix here with a little notice card
attribute that's cute
um i don't usually use them that often
but they're not bad obviously to use
probably a good thing
uh then we're taking the transform here
um i would probably
try and avoid copying this by the way so
taking this in by const reference is
probably a good idea so that we don't
um necessarily copy it either that or
you could take it as like an r value
reference if you want
um if you've got some kind of local kind
of variable that you want to just move
into there
the the point being that it is 64 bytes
um so it's probably worth saving the
copy there
uh initializing to identity by default
so this is again something that i would
reconsider the reason being that you've
only got a single constructor
that is taking in a transform right so
this actually does nothing
at the moment it might as well not be
here because you're setting the
transform to be whatever you
take in the constructor so this is just
kind of just empty code that
um kind of uh you know is misleading
because
when you look at this you're like oh by
default is that empty but actually it's
not it's whatever you specify here i'm
not even sure if i would
necessarily have this class because
literally it's a matrix um it's just a
wrapper over
mat four and i definitely like to not um
clutter my code with things like this
okay submit
so we submit a vertex array we get that
base shader there we go that's what i
was talking about and then we submit a
transform so pretty simple
right we have a vertex array which
contains the buffer the vertex buffer
and the index buffer
so we have all the information we need
there to render the object we
specify the we'll say material that we
want to render it with which is the
shader in this case
and then transform is the the transform
of the object
where do we want to render it in our 3d
scene and then of course we start the
scene with a camera so fairly
fairly kind of um standard i'll say
straightforward render
design here where we start like a
rendering context with like our camera
and our environment scene setup
and then we obviously proceed to
actually submitting entities for
rendering
by specifying uh both their actual
physical like vertex
buffer information as well as things
like materials and transforms okay and
then we end scene
i'm interested to see what this does um
yep okay so we're just literally taking
the view projection of the camera and i
guess copying it into the data
and scene does nothing i had a feeling
it would do nothing um and then we
obviously
of course set up our uniform matrices
from this shader obviously assuming that
they're there and then
calling and running command draw index
again very similar to
hazel uh and then that will actually
okay set um
polygon mode to fill so that we get
filled uh rasterized triangles here not
wireframe or anything like that
and then draw elements um in a pretty
standard way
um yeah i mean look uh
pretty simple pretty effective i think
obviously there's a lot of things that
you would want to change in the future
but you probably understand that and
this is
obviously a work in progress um you know
things like assuming
the uh primitive type as well as
assuming the fact that it doesn't unsign
into not like an unsigned short
so because obviously we can have uh you
know like 16-bit indices 32-bit indices
stuff like that
um and then obviously the fact that we
might not want to render the entire
vertex array at once in one draw course
and we might have like a mesh with
multiple
different materials in it for example um
but other than that you know it's it's
pretty simple i would say this almost
does too much
for a uh draw indexed command because in
hazel usually i like to keep these as
separate commands but it's i think it's
okay for this not a big deal
um default clear bits enum val
enum val okay just returns gl
all right that's the enum value of this
api um i notice your
code convention's a bit interesting as
well uh usually we like to like
capitalize
classes um you know the fact that you're
using like snake case for this is
totally fine a lot of people do that uh
but i
definitely have to say i don't like
classes not being capitalized i would
definitely capitalize them
because otherwise you can't you
literally can't tell the difference
between a class and a variable name or a
type
um or a type name or like a you know
function
um and it just gets a little bit
confusing
uh but other than that yeah it looks
pretty solid to be honest
if we look at real api um and just see
what it kind of maps to here so we're
doing
dll export so i guess we're compiling
real as a dll which is fine
and uh i think i've covered pretty much
everything and then of course we have
like an event
uh kind of person again things like you
know ev
like um i would just write the word
event
you know like this to make it really
quite
simple um to understand because in
general like i mean i personally believe
that writing code
you know you don't want to write overly
verbose code but
in my experience it's better to just
write code that might be
a little bit longer but make a lot more
sense
than code that is short and
only makes sense to you and also you
might forget about it in
the future i mean obviously on event
we're taking an event i guessed that
this is an event it's not particularly
difficult to read
but still like i mean you know try and
avoid um
classes called ev because i think that
that's uh just you know
unnecessarily uh difficult to read
okay then we've got a bunch of um and
this is kind of part of the event class
looks
similar to hazel's event class um
there's a few differences here i guess
is events yep so that we can just kind
of process different types and make sure
that
we are in fact dealing with something
that is a derived class from
our base event class okay cool um yeah
pretty standard i think pretty simple
windows window so i guess this is the
window data for
the window okay so we have a client
window and we derive from
the kind of game engine window okay
that's interesting
window dimension t i would also say
avoid so many custom types right so key
code t mouse button t
mouse position t window dimension t
window position t
like this is all very unnecessary just
have a just use uint 32t or in
32t or just int even i mean if it's not
a big deal and you don't really care
about like the uh
exact number of bits i think that in
general like
i remember when i was a little bit
younger and i
was learning about cbs plus and i'm like
oh my goodness you can make any type
you want i probably also went crazy and
made a billion types
don't do that it's really annoying um
and it doesn't help at all
so just you know change this to just be
either an m32t
or even just an int or i mean like a
window width can't really be negative so
i'd probably
write something like um32t like that
really easy to understand
and you don't have to have uh long names
you know here you use a long name but
event gets shortened to ev so yeah
okay oh we've got some move moves going
on here so that's kind of nice i was
going to say that in general strings
like i like taking strings in by const
reference most most of the time
this is a good uh opportunity or a good
place to not do that right
so if you take it in by value it's a lot
easier to kind of move it in here
presuming that we move it into title
into this constructor in the first place
which might not happen
but there are some optimizations you can
do with move semantics if you take
strings by value
so i don't want to say that it's like a
hard rule that strings have to be const
reference because they
they don't and in a lot of cases you can
get away with um
well rather it will be preferable to
take them in by either value or like has
a string view or something like that
um i don't want to really get into too
much of that but the point my point is
this is interesting this is nice to see
as well
um and then yeah i don't know things
like moving callbacks like
i'm not sure that i would do that um
uh but um i guess it's not
it's definitely not harmful okay um
blah blah blah okay so it i mean in
general i'm just saying and
i'm just saying an extraordinarily large
window class
like why is this stuff not in the base
window
like this is you know this
almost feels like windows when oh it is
windows window okay right this is
windows window it's just that it's
inside the example
or at least uh is it inside the example
maybe it's just like linked somehow
yeah it doesn't look like it is cmags
just included this
okay never mind so this isn't actually
in this if we look at where the file
resides in it's actually inside the real
engine
inside the engine i thought that it was
inside the example project because
that's what maybe
cmake has included it because i guess
it's used inside main
um in some way or another anyway it's a
bit weird thing in here
but i guess that that makes sense that's
very similar again to hazel
um and then we've got input again with
the positions um
with the type of the custom type so i'll
get rid of those uh and also i wouldn't
use
um i don't know if i noticed this before
actually but i wouldn't use
header guards like this anymore it's not
like the 90s i would just
write pragma once because i know that
it's technically not part of the
standard or whatever but it's
it's supported by every compiler and
pretty much everyone uses it so i would
just use bracket once
okay cool um i think that pretty much
covers it so in general uh
i mean i guess good work i i definitely
question some of your
naming conventions and some of your kind
of uh different types that you've made
um as well as just some of the api
design obviously this is all work in
progress and you did mention that you're
17 and you're just kind of inspired by
hazel and following along so for that
obviously you've done a really good job
i'm clearly very heavily inspired by
hazel there's a lot of architecture
that's very similar to that which is
obviously nice to see because that's the
point of making the game engine series
in the future
uh for those of you watching let me know
if there's something in the code that
that
um that i've missed maybe and that you
noticed that i should point out or that
you wanted to point out
i want this to be more of a community
thing i mentioned this before but i'm
not like some kind of
um you know c plus was god that just
corrects people
people's codes in absolute perfect kind
of fashion
this is all my opinion if you disagree
with it leave a comment below
share your thoughts instead um and then
we can kind of even though it's me
looking at this
is kind of i guess us doing it together
and i was even thinking about adapting
this to be more like a live stream
format maybe right even here on this
youtube channel
so that it can just get you know proceed
to be like a uh
uh like a youtube video once it's done
but you know with kind of like chat or
something like that
we'll we'll think about the format in
the future but in general uh let me know
what you thought of this code review if
you did enjoy it please don't forget to
hit the like button
if you have some code that you want me
to check out submit it below i'll try
not not to do a game engine next time i
would love to like look at a little game
maybe um or just some other kind of cool
project that you've made so if you've
got something interesting then
definitely
submit it and also one thing that i've
kind of realized throughout this episode
is that maybe it's
it's a good idea for me to kind of pick
a pick a subject
just while i'm going through code in
like one of these code review episodes
just
like pick a subject like in this in this
case it was almost like the cube right
and just hone in on that and talk about
that kind of in more depth
rather than trying to quickly read
through all of the engine code and
i don't know with this project i felt
like it was a little bit more i guess
overwhelming to try and get through it
in a timely fashion
than like the other project and i think
that maybe maybe it would be more useful
to people if i just
kind of use the code as an example and
maybe just give a brief
overview of the coding style and just
the the different kind of
way that it's architected but then also
you know focus in on something specific
let me know what you think in the
comment section below
don't forget that you can get a free
trial for skillshare by using my link in
description below
and i will see you guys next time
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
foreign